[Musique]
on utilise et recycle des échantillons
de peau humaine issus de chirurgie
plastique qui normalement sont détruits
pour en faire des plateformes
technologiques
qui permettent de tester l'efficacité et
la toxicité des médicaments et aider nos
clients à sécuriser le développement des
médicaments jusqu'à la fin des phases
cliniques
notre plateforme ipos king qui permet de
tester les produits d'injection permet
de tester des vaccins de comprendre déjà
l'efficacité du vaccin et qui se passe
dans les premières étapes dans la peau
comprendre si les cellules immunitaires
sont activés ou pas par les vaccins et
le avantages de cette approche par
rapport à des essais cliniques qui sont
nécessaires par rapport à des tests chez
les animaux c'est que c'est très rapide
à mettre en place aussi à partir des
échantillons de peau quand et qu'ils ont
peut tester plusieurs médicaments
plusieurs vaccins plusieurs conditions
en parallèle
on a été publique notamment l'année
dernière avec une société qui s'appelle
catalyst bioscience qui est basé dans la
silicon valley aux états unis et on les
a aidés à finalement repêché un candidat
médicament qui étaient en face d'eux
pour lequel il observait des réactions
de toxicologie forte chez les patients
et se demandait s'il n'allait pas tout
simplement arrêté
le développement à cause de ses
problèmes toxicologie donc on les a
aidés à mieux comprendre la cause de ce
problème et à identifier des solutions
c'est-à-dire différents types de
formulation pour éviter le problème est
maintenant ils sont de retour dans la
course des essais cliniques pour aller
jusqu'au bout et marketés ce produit
anti hémophiles
[Musique]